hey there everyone by the time you watch
this hopefully
touchwood
we're going to be heading to chile and
more specifically to the european
southern observatory now this all looks
pretty cool
we're really excited about getting to
see these places and more importantly
make videos about them now i'm going to
be traveling with professor mike
merefield an astronomer who you know
from loads of our videos of course
and pete lawrence he's appeared in a few
deep sky videos and he's a really
world-class astro imager this is some of
his work now we've already got a really
long list of all the things we hope to
see and do and ask about and record but
we'd really like to hear from you guys
about what you'd like to see what you'd
like us to look at and ask because after
all the videos we're making are for you
so leave comments under the video you
can also use twitter and facebook and
all those things but we'll be looking at
all the comments here under the video
while we're traveling and we'll do our
best to deal with some of your questions
now all these videos when they're made
well some of them are going to be here
on 60 symbols and a lot of them are also
going to be on our astronomy channel
called deep sky videos if you don't know
about deep sky videos well you probably
should because there's going to be some
brilliant stuff coming there in the next
few months that's all for now
talk to you when we get back and
hopefully we'll have lots of cool stuff
to show you and tell you about